it's time for a palate cleanser it's
time for our seen and unseen segment
where we explore the big cultural
stories of the day cancel sitcom the
first lady's Christmas trees in a
demonic children's clothing line from a
famous singer no doubt joining us now
with all the details Raymond Arroyo Fox
News contributor New York Times
bestselling author of the will while
their series beautiful covers Rehman
illustrated them himself
don't worry didn't know I didn't I
approve any of those gifts well I did
help shake Thank You Raymond let's begin
with Candace bergens much-touted Murphy
Brown returned and and it's been
canceled I want to start it cancelled it
was cancelled because the ratings
started really low Roseanne premiered
with 18 million people tuning and this
thing barely broke six million lefty not
what we want to say on TV what did we
say when this premiered watch this was a
strident even reviewers called it
strident heavy-handed not
character-driven at all can I say
there's two words okay not funny
only 7.4 million people tuned in to this
premiere
Candice Bergen is using a very wooden
Murphy Brown to communicate her politics
and I don't think the audience is going
to accept this I don't come up with a
new idea well they haven't accepted it
it has been cancelled as we prophesied
now the problem here Laura is it went so
political it wasn't about the characters
it was about the politics this is a
recent episode all about ice and
migrants watch oh no we received a call
from a neighbor here about a taco truck
Coran the plate seems the truck belongs
to a Carlos and Maria Gonzalez
undocumented immigrants outstanding
removal order you guys cannot barge in
here like this I know you're used to
dealing with people who were scared and
vulnerable but if you don't get out of
this truck
I will spatchcock you Charlie McCarthy
has more on the bowl today that was very
candid with Joy Behar
the other day about what this whole
series was really about it was all
political
get shot yeah Oh what is that if the
election had gone differently we would
not have brought it back but so it's
because of Trump that it's back yes is
that what you're saying yes it is
so if without Trump there wouldn't have
been a show Diane English the creator
says we're not really cancelled we
always wanted 13 episodes we may be back
don't worry Designing Women and Cagney &
Lacey are coming back soon I don't think
they're gonna make it either let's move
on to something really scary tell us
this new gender-neutral clothing line
yes singer Celine Dion let them have
those things
yes pushing no one that gets that joke
except us okay it's going on this line
is called Celine nunu nunu I swear to
God Celine nunu nunu and this is the
website it says to liberate children
from the traditional roles of boy and
girl it's to amplify the discussion
about a humanistic education which is
gender-free she rolled out this new
fashion line and it's in conjunction
with an Israeli fashion line with this
very bizarre ad she walks into a
maternity ward blows glitter around the
room all the boys are in blue the girls
are in pink not after she does her magic
and then in one of the bassinets this
big voodoo doll appears it's a very
strange line see it on the right-hand
side of your screen see it okay why is
that enticing for clothing let me show
you the bizarre fashions okay these are
gender-neutral but they're very dark
there are skulls in the collection
why were you would put babies in skulls
I don't know bones lion Heron has
there's this all-seeing eye that's you
know a big thing with with that kind of
anti-fraud secret groups bizarre and
this group this new new new new
they have demonic designs with horned
hoodies for kids it was Halloween very
dark this is from their Instagram that
looks like something out of The Wizard
of Oz when the lollipop kids it's really
sealed by lakewell Celine Dion and the
founders of this brand explained
themselves in a CNN interview watch this
we're it's an intern a new trying to
shape the future of all human beings by
saying find your own individuality we
bring a new order as a concept into the
world do you know what you don't know
what they're gonna become later and you
don't want for them to have psychology
kima a problem of growth and say I'm
supposed to be like that I'm supposed to
say that I'm supposed to dress like this
because I'm a guy I'm a boy I'm supposed
to do no no you don't know hmm I think
that's what people are going to say
about this line Selina no no no no no no
no no this is gonna go the way of Murphy
Brown okay it's all gonna be rejected by
the cause I understand but unless you're
a member of the Addams Family or a
satanic cult why would you dress your
infant in this where they admitted about
that they're admitted what their goals
are no order they want a new order they
want to affect the culture change the
way people help her heart may go on her
sales are gonna go the way that of the
Titanic who are the helping hands
organizations Raymond do you think oh
this is a tease yeah you're moving on I
want her to put in insignia you know I
saw it has the crocodile I want the
sinking ship from Titanic because that's
where this line is headed now I've got
it okay now you go on mic drop Melania
Trump and her response to the Christmas
decoration gate that we're doing that on
Fox Nation so watch for Fox nation we
are we already done them we're out of
time okay we're out of time who are the
helping hands